هذا المنزل كما تشاهدون في الصوره تعرض
لقصف من قبل طائرات الاحتلال الحربيه
وهناك عدد من الشهداء والاصابات نتيجه هذا
القصف الذي تم من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
قبل قليل في منطقه حي الامل في غرب محافظه
خان يونس ما زالت طواقم الدفاع المدني
تعمل في هذه اللحظات من اجل انتشال عدد من
الشهداء في ظل الحديث عن مفقودين نتيجه
هذا القصف وهناك صعوبه بالغه في الوصول
الى هذا المنزل خاصه ان الشوارع ضيقه جدا
وهذه
منطقه معسكر او مخيم والبيوت متلاصقه جدا
مع بعضها البعض
لذلك يجد او تجد طواقم صعوبه بالغه في
الدخول الى هذا المنزل وانتشال عدد من
الشهداء وكذلك انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من
المصابين الذين يتواجدون اسفل انقاض هذا
المنزل المستهدف الى جانب هذا المنزل الذي
تم استهدافه هنا منازل ايضا قريبه ومحيطه
بالمنزل نظرا كما تحدثنا لتلا سق هذه
المنازل ايضا تعرضت
لاضرار بالغه كما تشاهدون في الصوره هذا
منزل
مجاور هنا
ايضا جزء من هذا المنزل
المجاور على ما يبدو
طابقين في
هذا
المكان
على
الدر
اطط
[تصفيق]
شويه سك شويه
سخ الباب سخ
الباب نز نزلها فا نزلها
نزلنا روح
الع يا شباب طريق يا
شباب اطلع بكرك على
جنب
[موسيقى]
يلا بخير طلعت الحمد لله صحتها كويسه بخير
بخير هي هي
البن البنت
بخير الحمد لله بخير
البنت كلهم بخير طلعت من تحت الانقاز هذ
الحمدلله
بخير الله